how much money do you make what was it
like meeting elon musk
hey welcome back to the channel a little
bit of a different video today i thought
i'd do a q a um the channel's grown a
ton and i thought it'd be interesting
just to answer some questions so let's
kick it off are you doing this
unscripted video because you got coveted
and you didn't have time to make a full
video that's ridiculous i can't believe
someone would ask that are you tom
holland's older brother i do get that a
lot uh no i'm not related to him but i
think it's a compliment he's a pretty
talented guy what is your educational
background so
i grew up in pasadena i went to high
school out here and then i went to
college in boston i studied economics at
northeastern university and i thought i
was going to go into finance but in my
junior and senior year i started using
python to run some more complex economic
models once excel kind of topped out and
i kind of saw how cool programming was
then i kind of shifted everything and
went into startups as soon as i
graduated i grabbed a friend from high
school moved to silicon valley and kind
of did the traditional startup school y
combinator thing no formal training in
technology really or i didn't study
computer science i just kind of picked
up software engineering and then
eventually started programming full-time
then ran a team and now i don't program
that much but i still have software
developers that res that report into me
and i feel comfortable managing uh
software engineers since i do know
enough about coding that's kind of the
second question here yeah can you code
yes i i definitely feel comfortable
saying i can code i'm not an amazing
programmer or anything i'm not
developing entirely new algorithms but i
feel comfortable writing python and
getting what i need to get done on the
internet and building things i know a
little bit of javascript i've messed
around with closure to learn what a lisp
is and how that works and i've written
some objective c for ios and i've
touched most of the programming language
a little bit but python's the one that i
keep coming back to uh because it's so
fun and so easy to use why did you leave
soylent so soylent was my first startup
was there from 2012 till about 2016
2017. great experience the company grew
tremendously we sold a ton of product
millions of dollars in sales the first
month
and then just kind of grew from there
there were 50 people at the company when
i left and that's a big part of why i
decided to move on and do a new startup
the company had grown so much we were
kind of out of that innovation mode and
we were more in execution let's just get
the product into every store let's just
distribute distribute that's the name of
the game so we hired a bunch of people
who know distribution really well and
kind of let them take over and then me
and one of my co-founders at soylent and
our creative director and our head of r
d were able to go and start this next
company lucy that helps people quit
smoking it sells nicotine products and
that company was just not that idea was
not appropriate for the soylent brand so
it had to be a different company so we
were able to step back and go build
something new it's always tough kind of
leaving this family that you've built
and stepping back from this this whole
team that you've built but it's kind of
a natural part of the startup
life cycle how much money do you make
this is a very funny question it's very
gauche to ask but on the internet when
you put videos out people naturally ask
you this type of thing so um as an
entrepreneur i don't make a lot of money
for my businesses because i am hoping to
sell the business and then i have equity
in the business so i usually benchmark
to other what other startups you're
doing and it's not a lot like free
series
seed like when the company's not raised
a lot of money i might pay myself 60k
that's what i've paid myself in the past
then post series seed series a territory
a little bit over 100k
and then once the company is really
growing maybe 200k but really every
dollar that you pull out of the business
while you're in that growth mode is a
dollar that you could be spending on
marketing or hiring someone or your
product or engineering so it's really
risky to take too much money out of the
business when you're still in that
growth stage the the
the real the real benefit of all of this
stuff is
you want to sell the business for a lot
of money and then you own equity so the
real question here like the better
question is like how much equity do you
have in in your companies and i always
try to find a
an even split between my co-founders on
the equity front that's kind of best
practice and that's what a lot of people
in
silicon valley preach
it doesn't always happen sometimes
someone's worked a little bit harder but
in general that's kind of where where
i've worked to get to what do you do in
your free time
so i don't have a lot of free time
because i have a full-time job with my
startup and then i have this youtube
channel and then i also have a 10 month
old son at home and he's obviously a lot
of work but when i do have free time i
mean i love to read i love to play video
games i love to listen to podcasts and
kind of just research technologies and
learn about things but it's mostly a lot
of work these days try and just kind of
like talk to people have interesting
conversations about technology in the
future that's like most of my free time
what are your favorite books
it's hard to name a specific favorite
book but i really liked super founders
by ali tommasob he's a venture
capitalist and he crunched all this data
about what makes a successful founder
like a founder that creates a billion
dollar company or bigger it disproves a
lot of misconceptions it's very
encouraging because kind of no matter
what your background is there's data
that supports that you can be a
massively successful founder so very
inspirational book but also very data
driven which i really liked and then i
really enjoyed tyler cowan's stubborn
attachments which was published by
stripe press which is really cool and it
just kind of talks about how we should
think about the modern economy and
capitalism and economics from a very
um aspirational
perspective and it's just a great it's
just a great book it's very very quick
read as well what youtubers do you watch
uh this is a great question i love
corridor crew i watch every single one
of their videos they're just incredible
i have played around with visual effects
i know a little bit of after effects in
cinema 4d so i know the tools that
they're using and it's just always
really entertaining really great
storytelling on that channel love them
obviously watch like mkbhd obviously
watch mr beast who doesn't smaller
youtubers obviously gary tan is like the
inspiration for my entire channel i love
what he what he does and i love him
personally
and then i've been watching these
interviews done by this guy jesse
michaels uh that are just crazy he
interviews a lot of people about ufos
but he also talks with crazy really high
profile tech people he's super well
connected in silicon valley so i highly
recommend his channel and then i also
like g zero world it's a bit more of a
corporate channel but it's run by this
guy ian bremmer he's this political
strategist not he's non-partisan but
he's just trying to tell you what's
going on in the world and very very
informative videos not clickbaity he
doesn't get a lot of views but it's a
really really valuable channel if you're
looking to understand kind of global
politics global global economics in a
way that's not controversial or or like
left-wing or right-wing it's just here's
what's actually happening in the world
so
great channel how do you make these
videos so
i get this question a lot
because it seems kind of crazy that
someone could put out a video
once a week and still have a full-time
job so i have a team i have a researcher
who helps me
write scripts and research facts and
generate ideas that's been really
helpful he doesn't help with every
script but on a few of them uh he's
really really nailed it i use a
teleprompter for most of these that
speeds things up i typically write the
scripts uh in google docs and then i
throw them up on the teleprompter read
them in there and then i have a great
editor who helps me
combine everything and get all that
great b-roll and add the music and kind
of speed things up and clean up any
mistakes so that's been a huge benefit
why did you start making youtube videos
i love this question because it took me
a long time to answer it myself
basically i was bored during the
pandemic i was locked down didn't have
anything to do my wife was also pregnant
so i really had a lot of free time on my
hands for the first time
in 10 years of being an entrepreneur all
these cool people were hanging out in
clubhouse they were socializing and i
realized that i didn't really have a way
to meet new people in technology meet
new founders talk to people and i was
just kind of bored so i decided to turn
on the camera start talking about things
the views started coming in it was
really really positive the comment
section was always really really
positive so i i thought it was really
cool but now i'm thinking about it like
it's a great way to meet people i think
it's a great way to meet young founders
that i can ultimately invest with or
advise i think it's just very important
that we have more positive tech content
on youtube if you look at a lot of the
big tech channels they're super negative
every channel is like thera knows this
we work that like blah blah blah every
channel everything's a scam everything's
a fraud and that's true there are some
bad companies out there but we don't
need to highlight them
100 of the time obviously the youtube
algorithm is very it leans towards
controversy it loves controversy people
click on things that are scams and
frauds and terrible destroy the end of
the world like very negative content but
i think it's really bad because i think
there are problems in the world i think
tech can be a solution to those problems
in many many situations so i think we
need more tech positive content and
that's a lot of what i'm trying to do
with this channel will you invest in my
company uh maybe it's happened i've met
a few people through youtube that i've
written angel checks into
their companies i don't do a ton of
investing um
but i like partnering with people that
are super ambitious and working on
really cool things so if you want to
pitch me
you can send me a brief description of
what you're working on on on twitter my
dms are open you can also send me a deck
or a doc or your website or something
like that
just don't ramble for a long time and
try and tell me your whole life story
because
it's really hard to respond to those
types of messages
now
i do think that you should be in a place
where you are ready to take investment
if you want to pitch me because
a lot of people are still at the very
early stages and they haven't really
crystallized like what the problem
they're working on is what the solution
is um and you need to be able to tell if
you're actually if you have the skill
set to go and
build the solution that you're thinking
of because you know i would love to
build a time travel machine but i have i
have no experience in how to do that so
that would be a bad startup idea will
you mentor me i give this question a
decent amount and the answer is probably
not um
basically
i don't really do consulting i don't
really do mentorships what i do is i
invest in founders that are building
companies so if you're building a
company and
you think you'd like to work with me to
reach out to me we'll talk and if i can
invest then i can mentor you for free
actually i'm giving you money and then
you can call me whenever you want um but
in terms of just like general mentorship
everything that i know i'm trying to put
out on this channel for free you can
still ask me questions you can dm me on
twitter and ask me a question i might
just answer it in a youtube video
instead of answering you directly what
technology are you most interested in
right now this is a good one i got this
after my 22 predictions of all the
interesting tech in 2022. basically i
think of there's three really
interesting buckets that are going on
right now one is ai then there's space
like space travel space exploration
everything that elon's doing with spacex
and then there's crypto and crypto
obviously is like a huge trend
everyone's everyone's talking about
crypto out of those three buckets i
think they're all really interesting i
think they're all really impactful and
important but out of those three ais the
one that
is the most intriguing to me just
because that's the one that i've
actually tinkered with like i've written
python code that does ai stuff and i
also can just immediately imagine how
that's beneficial to me like if i had a
self-driving car in my driveway that
would make my life better today whereas
if you told me i could go to mars like
it'd be really really cool but like
that's a really harsh environment i
don't know that that's gonna make my
life better immediately it's kind of
unclear the value in the short term and
then with crypto obviously you can make
a ton of money but there aren't that
many people that are actually getting
like real tangible day-to-day value they
certainly are internationally if you're
if you're in a country where there's a
lot of hyperinflation crypto can be
great for you or if you're trying to
transfer money across borders constantly
and you need low fees that's possible or
if you're being de-platformed and you
need a censorship resistant technology
like crypto could definitely deliver on
that but i'm in america i'm not being
de-platformed um i don't need to send
money all over the world for really low
fees so all of the main crypto benefits
to me aren't as impactful like it's cool
that you could make money if you trade
it effectively but that's a lot less
exciting than like a robot that does my
laundry or something like that like
that's why i'm personally excited about
ai it just seems so intuitive that it
would be beneficial it's just like it's
already here we're using ai all the time
there's always a new app that's that's
doing something with ai
that's why that's why i just love it
what do you think about crypto
specifically crypto obviously the
markets are in turmoil everyone's losing
a ton of money i still think that crypto
is
cool and beneficial and worth pursuing
and worth having i just don't
necessarily think it's the only thing
that we should be focusing on like i
don't see a world where crypto cures
cancer
you have to get it's a real stretch to
say that crypto is going to like create
more economic efficiency and that's
going to be the thing that cures cancer
it's like
maybe or like maybe you're storing some
cancer data on the blockchain and then
that somehow becomes relevant to cancer
researchers it's a real stretch i think
crypto's good i just don't think it's
the only good technology which is what a
lot of like maxis think a lot of
maximalists think what was it like
meeting elon musk
this is funny i actually haven't met
elon musk he has tried soylent though we
set up a
food truck in downtown l.a and he just
like stopped by which was cool
so i saw a photo of him drinking soylent
which was awesome his chief of staff
invested in my company which was cool
and i've been to events where he's been
there but i haven't actually gotten to
meet him yet now i don't know that i'd
have a lot to ask him even though
obviously i make videos about him all
the time i think what would be more
interesting would be for
him to talk to another expert that can
actually debate him on some of these
points i really want to see him debate
vitalik about crypto and i would love to
see him talk to george hotz about
self-driving cars because i feel like
they would have a much better
conversation than i ever could have with
someone like that so yeah i think in
general i want to see more debates
between
world experts as opposed to just more
every individual expert goes around to
all of the podcasters and they do
individual interviews that are okay but
they don't really ever come into contact
with each other i think that that's what
would be really really entertaining we
used to have debates but we don't really
have them anymore because they're very
very risky to participate in well that's
it if you have any more questions just
leave me a comment below and if you're
not already subscribed please subscribe
because there's more videos coming soon
thanks a lot
[Music]
you